we begin this broadcast with some
breaking news as we come on the air
several people have reportedly been
injured in a shooting in the german city
of heidelberg
according to police an assailant shot at
people in a lecture hall at the
heidelberg university police say the
attacker is now
dead
and dw reporter amyan asif joins me here
on the set he is closely tracking these
developments so what more have you
learned amy
well what we've learned is that um the
only confirmed death so far is the
perpetrator himself
local media is reporting that he was a
student
that he was a student at this university
and there's no religious or political
motivations found by investigators so
far local media also reported we don't
really know how many people were injured
thus far but
local media has reported about four
people have been confirmed to be among
the injured now the weapon he used was a
rifle that was also reported by police
um and
uh as i said there are no known
motivations behind this attack but of
course this only happened a little while
ago so they're still under investigation
now this happened in on the heidelberg
university campus it's in downtown
heidelberg the city itself is only about
160 000 people and the students there
about 30 000 so this is really a city
built around the university this
happened at the heart of the city and
it's also germany's oldest university
this is a place where a lot of
international students come to study in
germany because for a lot of people it
represents germany with
castle and old german culture a very
renowned academic institution as you
said how common is this type of incident
in germany would you say
it's very uncommon if you compare it to
a country like the united states where
school shootings happen multiple times
per year now there's only been six major
incidents of school shootings in germany
in the last century the first one being
just about a century ago
now the last major one was in 2009 where
nine students were killed at a secondary
school before that there was a major one
in 2002 but all in all this is a very it
doesn't happen very often in germany
given the gun laws given the culture
here that somebody brings the gun to
school um and opens fire on students and
i think this is why it's alarmed a lot
of people in germany right now all right
amir nassif reporting on that breaking
story where a gunman opened fire at
germany's heidelberg university thank
you so much for now thank you
you